congressman you heard the president what
you think I think the president did an
excellent job in defining the problems
and he deserves an enormous amount of
credit for finally raising this issue of
the crisis and health care and the
disintegration of our health care system
to the level that it deserves to be
raised however I think in terms of
implementing a policy who is interesting
the president talked about the savings
in the Canadian system we talked about
how the Canadian system is much more
administrative lee efficient we bought
up on canada and the fact of the matter
is in my view if you want a simpler
system if you want a more cost effective
system if you want a system that is
comprehensive and that is universal i
think we have a lot to learn from the
canadian system which provides
comprehensive health care to all of
their people without out-of-pocket
expense so i am one of the 89
co-sponsors of the single-payer approach
and we look forward to working with the
president i think what probably is going
to end up is going to be an amalgam
where at least those states that want to
go forward with the single-payer system
will be allowed to do so so i think the
president deserves an enormous amount of
credit for raising the issue for dealing
with it frontally for defining the
problems and it's going to be a very
interesting debate in the next eight
months and the hope out of all of this
is that the day will come within the
next few years that every single man
woman and child in this country will
have all of the health care that they
need without out-of-pocket expense in my
opinion and in a system which is far
more cost-effective than the very
wasteful system that we have today so
we're off to a good start there's a lot
of work in front of us and I think that
as a nation if we pull together we can
make it happen as the only independent
in the US Congress can you give us your
insight on how this will play out
politically will this be a bipartisan
effort
I think the president has made an effort
to make it a bipartisan issue i think
when we get down to the nuts and bolts
of it there will be those of us who will
say that the real cost savings are when
you begin to stand up to the
pharmaceutical industry well the
Republicans and some conservative
democrats support that I don't know when
you begin to demand that some physicians
do not make hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year in salary
will the AMA and some of the people in
Congress support that I don't know and
most importantly unfortunately the
president's proposal still gives an
enormous amount of responsibility and
power to the largest insurance companies
in America I myself personally don't
believe that you're going to have a cost
effective system which is going to be
run as the president's plan proposes by
very very large insurance companies
there's going to be a lot of contention
over those issues congressman Bernie
Sanders thank you very much cheaper